يا أطفالهم
هناك وهم يتسكعون في الظل
، سأحاول السير
بهذه الطريقة
ربما لا أكون قد مررت بالفعل
بهذا القطيع بمجرد أن أعتقد أنني سأحاول
السير في هذا الطريق بعد اجتيازهم
جميعًا  يستمر الرجال المناسبون في الذهاب إلى هناك
لأطفالك ، إنه مثل شعور زائف
بالأمان
هناك ،
استمر في العمل
قبل أن يكون لدي مسافة أكبر عندما
كنت أقترب من ذلك بكثير.
لم يكن يريد
المرور عبر الأدغال مرة أخرى
عندما رأيته يستدير ، كما لو كنت أعرف
أنه سيخرج ،
يا
إلهي ، لقد ركض نحوي في الخلف ،
قلبني غوردون وهو
يقلبني ويقلبني إلى الداخل  وجه المسكيت بوش في
البداية ظننت أن ظهري
سينكسر ، لقد أصابني بشدة ووقف
هناك معظم الدقائق الخمسين التي كنت
أرقدها في الأدغال ، لذا كان
كما لو أنه لا يمكنك العودة إلى هذا الحد
الغريب
[  موسيقى]
البحث وأدركت أنه حتى أنا
أحدق في عينيه عندما كنت
أمشي  كان يهدده وما كان
يجب
أن أفعله ولن أضحك مرة أخرى